Einem forschungsteam aus japan ist etwas unglaubliches
gelungenes hat die superkräfte in der bärtierchen
in menschliche zellen eingeschleust sie überleben nämlich jede katastrophe egal ob radioaktiver unfall
gigantische chemie katastrophe oder die komplette austrocknung der erde wie das genau funktioniert und ob wir jetzt alle superhelden werden
ein video in zusammenarbeit mit der mega polen zeitschrift technology review
am ende des videos gibt's ein gratis exemplar für euch als geschenk klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Optisch gesehen sind bärtierchen alles andere als außergewöhnlich sie sind verwandt mit dem gliedertieren also beispielsweise den spinnenmann
findet sie zwischen alten blättern und moos und um sie zu entdecken brauchen wir eine lupe sie sind etwa einen millimeter lang
haben einen rundlichen körper und acht beinchen doch forschungsteams weltweit sind mehr als angetan von diesem kleinen kirchen denn sie sind wahre überlebenskünstler
weder lange trockenheit noch
radioaktivität können ihnen etwas an namen setzen eine chemie katastrophe unsere umwelt zerstören würde wären die bärtierchen wohl immer noch am start
und das wohl bei bester gesundheit doch wie kann das sein wie sind diese lebewesen in der lage quasi wieder aufzuerstehen
nachdem ihr kompletter lebensraum monatelang ausgetrocknet war fest steht die dna tierischer zellen ist dafür nicht
ausgelegt bleiben wir beim beispiel des wasser entzuges die molekülketten brechen bei derart
lebensfeindlichen bedingungen auseinander auch bei
radioaktiver strahlung die in den zellkern gelangen sieht es schlecht aus für das erbgut doch bärtierchen
überleben strahlendosen achtung bis zu 1000 dre das ist absoluter wahnsinn wenn man sich mal überlegt dass helfer nach der reaktorkatastrophe
von tschernobyl bei strahlendosen von 2 bis 20 grad
starb erst 2017 war ein forschungsteam aus japan dem geheimnis der bärtigen auf die schliche gekommen
eine schutzhülle rund um das erbgut der lebewesen fängt alle schädlichen einflüsse ab dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
von der universität tokio takeda zu boney m
sie können einfach so zwischen leben und beinahe toten hin und her wechseln da unglaublich konkret handelt es sich um ein protein
das das erbgut vor schäden bewahrt in der fachsprache genannt
vorstellen kann man sich das tatsächlich wäre eine art
superhelden kate an der dna befestigt ist es durch elektrische anziehung aber das eben nur an der einen
seite an der anderen seite flattert es locker herum und sorgt so für den schutz das hatten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler bei den strahlungs tolerantesten aller bisher bekannten bärtierchen dem sogenannten ramazzottis
vario natus herausfinden können und das forschungsteam ging noch weiter
das ziel war es diese superkräfte auch auf menschliche zellen zu übertragen gesagt getan auch hier wurde das erbgut mit dem entsprechenden protein
ausgestattet ja und haltet euch fest die so manipulierten seelenleben trotz einer tödlichen bestrahlung von vier gray nicht nur weiter sondern
teilten sich sogar weiterhin ein wirklich
vielversprechend das ergebnis was allerdings so nicht so 100 prozent auf den menschen übertragbar ist denn die für das
experiment genutzten zellen wurden so verändert dass sie eher
krebszellen ähnlich sind und nicht normalen körperzellen doch der japanische forscher nun jeder ist dennoch
optimistisch wenn wir verstehen was bärtierchen so stark macht dann können wir diese stärken später einmal auf weniger starke spezies übertragen
menschen eingeschlossen war vielen dank an die redaktion von
technology review für das ama thema und noch weitere unglaubliche themen gibt es in dem gratis heft dass ihr bekommt wenn er
darauf klickt also klicken und staunen wenn ich mal sagen und hier darunter geht es weiter mit einem anderen coolen thema von technology review
dafür auch draufklicken
mysteriöse grauzone zwischen leben und tod
wachkomapatienten bei bewusstsein bis dahin
bleibt dran